the jurogan experience that just shows
you what a cracker dustin poirier is
the fact that max holloway who beats the
[ __ ] out of calvin kater and says i'm
the best boxer in the
in the ufc and dustin's like hold on
says hold my hot sauce do you not
remember what the [ __ ] just went down
yeah dude just hold on here dustin
poirier is a bad [ __ ]
yeah he's a bad [ __ ] he really
is he takes him out to fight
because me and theo you know theo's a
big dust emporia fan because we're both
from louisiana
yeah and obviously i'm a conor dick
writer and so
and i love dustin i'm way closer with
dustin but just you know just for the
show it's fun to bet
and so i bet uh theo a thousand dollars
cash whoa so
as soon as dust i don't know why i
thought this as soon as he got backstage
he almost got to his phone
text me pay feel his money
[Laughter]
like yeah congrats that must have been
on his head yeah
right afterwards you know it's all love
man can't wait to tweet
yeah you can't say that with a fighter
you bet against a fighter you can't say
it yeah
yeah they get mad take it personal they
do well they're very
emotionally invested that's how they
should be yeah what do you what do you
do with dustin nicks
well there's two options we talked about
this no i have not but there's the
purest
option the purest option is charles
oliveira that's
as if you're a purist you want that
fight and i think i want that fight that
should be the right thing to do if you
want to make a shitload of money before
conor
fights someone else you have the rematch
because oh no you can't do that well
here's the thing if conor fights michael
chandler next which is a possibility if
dustin fights
um charles oliveira and then conor
fights michael chandler what are the
odds that conor beats michael chandler
i think michael chandler is a favorite
in that fight 100
yeah and which is very dangerous for
your money
if you want to make a lot of money what
you do is
you you allow connor to have some time
off
you how wha you figure out a way to
market this
in a way that you explain away that
conor could figure out a way to beat
dustin
good luck good luck he did beat him in
the first fight and did rock him
in the second fight and conor actually
or excuse me dustin actually admitted
there was one point in the first round
where he was he was hurt
um and he was like if conor followed up
i might have been in trouble uh
but that might be dustin also saying
like i would like he's a great match
yeah he knows what's up and he also
might want that rematch i think yeah
look at that rematch
and this pains me to say this i think
you got to take connor out of the
equation
he's out he's not let me throw one more
variable go ahead
the covid restrictions get lifted dublin
ireland
soccer stadium
now here hear me out here dude and it
pains i love where your head's at
you got to take conor out of the
equation of the of the for the race for
the title because you got
yes what you're going to have is charles
oliveira dustin poury
michael chandler justin gaichy yes and
then connor they're over here they're
out of the tournament
you're going to have conover snake diaz
trilogy in dublin go ahead and do that
but they're not in the race well connor
versus nate diaz
is an excellent option it's an excellent
option
because that doesn't offend anyone like
myself time off
yep give him some time off um it doesn't
offend anyone
and nate is not the kind of kicker that
dustin is he's much more of a boxer
it falls into connor's wheelhouse more
and nate is also
insanely durable and nate also has
a finish over connor connor does not
have a finish overnight at 55
is where this thing should be settled
yes
but they're out of the conversation of
title titles charles oliveira justin
gaichi michael chandler
yes that's what a lot of people are very
offended that charles
excuse me that michael chandler gets an
immediate
jump right into almost title contention
with one knockout over dan ho then you
don't know the history of michael
chandler
that's true but then you're talking
about a former multi-time world champion
bellators fighting the who's who over
there
how to finish over ben henderson but
patricio pitbull knocked him out how
long ago
yeah but and who's a smaller guy but
he's also has a win over him too
he does well i know he has a win over
his brother oh that's right patricki
yeah that's right he ko'd his brother
and then patricio
uh uh got revenge but
he's a two division champion in bellator
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience